[Music]
good ideas start as crazy ideas and then
at some point they occur then they
become why haven't we been doing that
all along we are right now in that
transition for changing the way people
think about the moon the Apollo missions
were like Christopher Columbus and the
early explorers that came over to the
new world this generation right now is
like the Mayflower it's time to go back
it's time to discover the riches of the
new world we need to go back to stay we
need to go back to push humanity beyond
Earth we need to go back to become a
multi-planet species
[Music]
ginger is like Pittsburgh speak for
y'all or you all could you use Ensor in
a sentence how are u n--'s doing or are
yinz hot or cold or shy adjust the
temperature a little Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania what's the first thing you
think of my bet is steel mills or maybe
the Steelers you're probably not
thinking of a new space company that has
visions of becoming FedEx to the moon
meet John Thornton co-founder and CEO of
a little startup called Astrobotic I
came to Carnegie Mellon to study
mechanical engineering so for me space
was something that I discovered at
Carnegie Mellon it was something that I
stumbled upon a combination of robotics
and space and it just clicked with all
of my passions that's when Google XPrize
was announced the Google Lunar XPrize
for us is not just a mission it's a new
way of doing business it's a new way of
inspiring a cadre of math and science
engineers technologists around the
planet to dream big the Google Lunar
XPrize is a 20 million dollar prize to
land on the moon drive 500 meters and
send back HD video and imagery and that
just was incredibly exciting and
immediately we knew we were going to put
our hat in the ring we signed up days
after it was announced and we were one
of the first teams to get on board as
fate would have it one of John's
professors was a guy named red Whittaker
who in the world of robotics is kind of
a giant at the time the XPrize was
announced he was just coming off winning
the two million dollar DARPA Grand
Challenge in which he and his students
designed some of the first self-driving
cars there's always the question what's
next and everyone needs a new rodeo and
the XPrize came along at just that
moment when I heard about it I knew that
it was for me
and
there was no questions to swing for it
twenty million dollars it sounds like a
lot of money but it turns out that it
costs a lot more to get to the moon
quickly we realized that we needed to
build a business to make that possible
and the XPrize became an enabler and a
catalyst to get things started I think
it goes without saying that starting any
sort of business is really hard but a
business built around going to the moon
hard doesn't even begin to describe it
so in the early going we had a few
different business models we played a
little bit with payload idea but there
was also a bigger idea of data services
so the idea was that data would be
collected on the moon and sold as
subscriptions to space agencies all over
the world turned out after testing that
model it wasn't working what John's not
telling you is that Astrobotic almost
went out of business and they probably
would have had they not had a
breakthrough they were already building
a lander to take their Rover to the
lunar surface what if other
organizations had stuff they wanted to
send to the moon too and what if they
were willing to pay for that service the
delivery business is no mystery post
office has been around for a long time
companies like FedEx DHL make their
money by delivering packages the only
difference with Astrobotic is that we
delivered to the surface of the Moon
so let's say your space mining company
and you need to send some equipment to
the surface of the Moon Astrobotic can
get you there or if your University and
want to run some experiments on the moon
but don't have the cash to Commission
your own rocket you get it to ride with
Astrobotic the possibilities are endless
Astra biotics goal is to make the moon
accessible to the world and towards that
what we are creating is an affordable
routine delivery service to the moon
where space agencies and commercial
organizations and even individuals all
over the world can access the moon and
send their packages science instruments
Rovers even marketing campaigns to the
surface of the Moon we have 10 deals
toward mission 1 we're making the moon
accessible in ways that have never been
possible before
while the lunar xprize has yet to be won
and Astrobotic has yet to send anything
to the moon they already have 10 paying
customers nations and companies and
individuals who have put down real money
to put their stuff on Astrobotic slander
one of those paying customers happens to
be an X Prize competitor
Tokyo's very own team hock dough so most
people think about a prize as a
competition we took a very unique
approach to that so we're flying to the
moon and we're competing with others
flying to the moon what we realized was
that those other people flying to the
moon could become partners and customers
of our service we reached out to the
community and team hakuto in particular
stood up and they had just a rover at
the time and they needed a hitchhike to
the moon everybody talks about
democratizing space but what's really
cool about the Astrobotic team honto
partnership is they're actually doing it
in fact team jato has an army of
everyday people who volunteer their time
hoping to be a part of Japan's first
mission to the moon
no he's Michael Carrera de todo hasta
que de mama this melody camasta esto
tiene la station motto innovation tanaga
a MIDI click on kidnapped each team's
the Paradis net Hema analogy Ingrid a
total solitude a man and a water snake a
local psychologist our a dioxide food
Ahmadis net a honcho Kamata sorry o casa
good hey Josh Oklahoma Texas Fatiha
seumas toka ma ma coo coo dhaba it's
evil to quit or Steve noir and get some
enjoy welcome a Toyohashi council
robotic is suitable this the robotics
woman d'Ivoire and set a máquina de
Senado the skirt amor
Hayato stretchy near a son or daughter
kids many hands any chakra casa de esto
el americano
Astrobotic 13 de ichiban Sano gets man
chocolate
NASA photo partnership promotion day day
skinny or ITA's Madiba ishani Kyoko
Giotto
the skinny Olli Tutera Kandra Mata
Marini Roberto stay a cure so Rizzo
Colorado Astrobotic near Cazadores
our goal is to make the moon accessible
to the world and that includes our
competitors and includes partners that
want to fly to the surface so we are
accomplishing our goal because we are
proving our delivery service model they
are accomplishing their goal because
they can send their Rover to the moon
and compete in the google lunar xprize
so it's a true win-win partnership
sequence I'm sure some people are
thinking we've kind of already done the
moon we went there in the 60s right why
spend all this time and money to go back
humanity has an inevitable destiny in
space and a moon landing enterprise is
absolutely essential to deep-space
exploration development and science that
is yet to come the moon is our nearest
neighbor and it's a place where we will
need to go to learn to live off the land
it's the natural next step this is the
moment in history when people will look
back and say that this is the turning
point for pushing humanity deep into
space there is no uninventive and there
is no going back these transformations
are forever
[Music]
[Music]
you